[Music]
brian is with us in atlanta georgia to
start off this hour hey brian how are
you
doing well how about you dave better
than i deserve what's up
perfect um
okay so
just a short background i i've come from
a
poor family
poor mindset
financially and everything
and as i've gotten older i have you know
i i didn't follow on those footsteps
i mean i'm debt-free
uh
married
and
you know i
like to maintain healthy boundaries and
i'm a small business owner
and
the
i
my income has risen drastically over
you know the past few years
congratulations
yeah
um
well right now we're about around 25 000
a month good for you man well done
yeah
so um
my family on the other hand you know
they
still do their thing and my wife her her
family's not
you know they're
they they do well so they're not like
this either so we don't get it from both
sides but
i guess what i'm asking is uh
what is the
when you're starting to comment like i'm
not i feel weird just even saying that
just because
al is raised
um
and i want to make sure that we are
the
i don't mind helping my family but
whenever they smell like
i don't know
uh like i just bought a house almost in
cash like we're gonna pay it off in like
a year
um
but
they they have controversy they have
emergencies and
you know like they make decisions that
cause them to be where they're at
and i don't like to enable them and so
they like to
put me on guilt trips and things like
that and
you know especially since i've been
married you know if if money's involved
you know i
tell them that well my wife has to be
involved in these conversations and
you're going to ask me for money and
and then
i don't really care for that because
they don't practice boundaries
so
okay so who is asking who's asked you
for money
um i mean my mother does on a very
regular basis and she is she singles
she's single she's on disability but
she's allowed to work 20 hours a week
and that's where i encourage her what i
encourage her to do
[Music]
and how much money have you given her
well dave i haven't given her money in
several years when i was younger in my
teens and early 20s i'm 34 now
um i used to give her money all the time
so when you stopped giving her money it
was how long ago
uh about 2015. okay so it's been six
years since you gave her any money and
she still asks right
she'll still ask oh my my mother's very
relentless with things and then recently
my brother has come into some
hard times and he'll ask and you know i
we've given him small amounts but you
know again discuss with my wife because
what's a small amount
um
like
four hundred dollars a thousand dollars
okay and so what what prompted this call
who asked you recently
um well my mom is trying to move
back to this area where i'm from and
she's
done everything but
like
it's all fit over the fact that i won't
like
pay for her move and get her here
you know you know what i mean just just
make it happen for her and the thing is
is i i've given her money in the past
and she's you know i've put her in a
house before and she literally burnt it
to the ground
um you know
years ago and so like i i think she's
healthier now in terms of like she her
addictions are no longer
in control of her life
but i definitely don't want to
um okay let's let's stop a minute all
right what i'm gonna do when we hang up
i'm gonna send you a copy of my friend
dr henry cloud's book boundaries
it is the absolute bible on this issue
um it is the best book and he sold 10
million copies and i love my copy it has
helped me
with so many things over the last 20
years and so you want to read that book
because you're going to read the first
chapter and just be laughing out loud
and go how did this guy know because
he's going to like read your mail okay
so what this teaches you is this
that you you are not under a moral
obligation to give
anyone
money
except your own spouse
and children who are minors that live in
your home
you're supposed to take care of them but
your brother and your mother you are not
under a moral obligation
just because you have the same blood
that they have
okay
yeah period
okay and no matter how big a fit they
throw
or no matter what so now once we've
removed that you're not under obligation
then you say okay under what
circumstances would i want to be
generous
right
and there's only one circumstance that
you want to be generous and that is
where you're actually helping someone
move
through their life
and get traction
helping someone is not assisting them in
continuing their stupidity
okay so buying a drunk a drink
is enabling it's not helping
now the drunk may throw a fit and say
you won't buy me my alcohol
and if you were a good son you'd buy me
my alcohol
right
and they may say all of that but that
doesn't make any of that true agreed
agree just because they say it doesn't
make it true
and so the definition of help
if you're not an enabler
means the person
moves on to the next stage of their
personal growth and their life is better
as a result of you having assisted
and so
in our case if it were sharon and i in
this kind of a situation although we've
not been in this exact situation
but the way for instance with ramsey
family foundation if we're helping a
family or an individual
on an ongoing basis now one time we
might buy somebody a truckload of
groceries and fill up their cabinets
okay just so they're not hungry that's
that's one that's a one-off though but
if i'm gonna assist mom in moving and
pay her rent for four months
she's going to produce some fruit in her
life that indicates that she's growing
into a sustainable life
meaning she's going to get a job and
keep it she's going to be on a budget
and keep it she's going to be in
financial peace university and i'm going
to pay for it and you're going to get
better mom you're going to get better
and better and better and better but i'm
not going to pay for you to get worse
and worse or stay the same
because that's not helping
that's enabling
and real love
requires that the person have a better
life as a result of being intersected
with you